françois bayrou est donc l'invité de bfm
politique ce dimanche monsieur bayrou
emmanuel macron dans une interview à l
agence france presse renouvelle sa
confiance à elisabeth bornes trois fois
ou quatre fois dans le texte de manière
très très appuyé cette semaine vous avez
marqué l'actualité en disant qu'elle
n'était pas suffisamment politique
qu'elle était trop technique est ce que
les gouvernants non est-ce que vous avez
perdu l'oreille du président ne se
battront soyez soyons précis parce que
autrement on va faire croire des
billevesées j'ai dit que le gouvernement
devait être politique je n'avais pas et
la première ministre non je n'ai je n'ai
jamais parlé
personnellement je suis je crois que
nous sommes au moment d'une mutation
obligatoire d'un changement obligatoire
pendant très longtemps on avait pu selon
un principe ou depuis 20 ou 30 ans on a
vécu selon un principe qui est que tout
se décide au sommet c'est pyramidale les
décisions sont prises
là haut le gouvernement les traduit et
la majorité votre pour emmanuel macron
c'est la super incarnation ce que vous
dites à l'instant et bien je suis non
d'abord je crois qu'il a d'autres
aspirations et ceux ci y viendra mais je
sais je sais que ça ne peut pas
continuer comme ça je sais qu'on est
obligé de prendre en compte le message
que les français ont envoyé parce que
c'est un message qui en réalité étaient
en préparation gestation depuis très
longtemps le
la mauvaise impression que les français
ont
qu' ils ne sont pas pris suffisamment en
compte au moment des décisions que on
n'entend pas ce qu'ils ressentent ce
qu'ils vivent et ce qu'ils disent donc
c'est pour ça que j'ai demandé des gens
du camp politique parce que vous estimez
plus proche des gens que des techniciens
qui par définition arguant des cabinets
par définition oui parce que ce que ce
que j'appelle politique c'est des femmes
et des hommes souvent élus
ils ont passé beaucoup d'années à
essayer de comprendre l'opinion peu mais
monsieur bayrou parle et elisabeth
borrel ne répond pas à cette définition
est bien le choix du président de la
république a été de confirmer la
première ministre de lui donner sa
confiance et notre travail à nous le
mien ce sera de l'aider autant que
possible et vous le regrettez mais j'ai
confiance je n'ai je n'ai jamais aveu je
n'ai jamais présenté des choses sous cet
angle alors je répète je pense que nous
sommes au moment où il est nécessaire où
il est obligatoire de changer le rapport
entre pouvoir et citoyens
ce message a été répété par le corps
électoral a suffisamment de reprise pour
qu'on le prenne au sérieux
je vous rappelle que c'est aussi le
message que le président de la
république avait entendu au moment des
gilets jaunes et du grand débat et il
avait dit qu'il allait le prendre en
compte il a dit au moment de l'élection
présidentielle
je suis pour qu'on le prenne en compte
sérieusement oui mais alors pour le coup
je veux dire on pourra donc je vous
engage rondelle et s'il a présenté dans
pardonnez moi monsieur bayrou s'il a
pris en compte il a pourtant de nommer
un gouvernement de techniciens ce qui
vous a conduit en début de semaine à
dire ce que vous avez dit et là il
renouvelle sa confiance et une
technicienne se dire que vous dans
l'équipe qui sera conduite la fin
construite pour début juillet vous
attendez qu'il y ait des politiques
entre deux portes et de la politique au
sens où la politique et compréhension de
ce que les gens disent et imagination
créativité
invention d'une nouvelle de nouvelles
formes d'organisation du pays et de la
société on a besoin de tout ça on a
besoin d'entendre on a besoin le
gouvernement doit se sentir libre et il
doit imaginer le temps où le
gouvernement était seulement la courroie
de transmission
du président de la république et le
parlement une chambre d'enregistrement
ce temps là pour moi est fini et il est
nécessaire qu'ils le soient et ils
soient bons qu'il le soit je me suis pas
battue pendant des années pour la
proportionnelle pour oublier ce que ce
que je disais ce que je portais dans ce
message là et donc je ferai tout ce que
je pourrai pour aider le gouvernement
pour aider la première mine str à
entendre et à construire cette nouvelle
relation tout ce que je pourrai parce
que le l'idée que je me fais des
institutions c'est peut-être pas la
première fois que je le dis à votre
micro l'idée que je me fais des
institutions c'est un président fort on
en a besoin c'est un atout pour la
france la vème république qui est
quelqu'un pour trancher quand on est
bloqué on a besoin d'un gouvernement
fort
avec de l'autonomie qui ne soit pas
uniquement la duplication
de
de ce qui a été dit pendant la campagne
présidentielle et on a besoin d'un
parlement fort où toutes les
sensibilités sont reconnues vous voyez
bien que qu'on est là devant un paysage
institutionnel complètement nouveau
monsieur je le ferai tout ce que je
pourrai vous savez
galilée
c'est immense savant au xviie siècle
il avait prétendu que la terre tournait
autour du soleil alors à ce moment-là
tous les arcs tous les
spécialistes dans les religions surtout
dans l'étude notamment à l'intérieur de
l'église lui ont fait un procès en
disant que c'était scandaleux que
c'était le contraire que et on l'a
obligé à renoncer à ses thèses et quand
il a renoncé à cette asie s'est mis à
genoux pour renoncer à ses thèses et en
se levant il a dit et pourtant elle
tourne cette gamine et et moi je dis oui
et pourtant il va falloir changer voilà
on peut on peut on peut choisir toutes
les configurations sellam le privilège
du président de la république car si je
promets un gilet rose vous êtes galilée
qui sont ceux qui vous jugent qu'ils
sont ceux qui ne croient pas à ce que
vous dites
il ya un très grand nombre dans la vie
politique française de de force ou de ou
deux
de corde de rappel qui
depuis longtemps
pense que ça n'est pas nécessaire pense
que c'est superflu pense que tout ça
c'est du blabla
vous savez je ne raconte jamais mes
conversations avec lui mais je peux vous
dire ceci moi je crois que ce n'est pas
ce qu'il pense ou ce n'est pas
uniquement ce qu'ils pensent alors
françois bayrou juste je sais pas si
galilée était candidat pour entrer à
matignon mais le cas vous vous somme
vous aviez en quelque sorte dessiner en
creux le portrait d'un potentiel premier
disque qui étonnamment vous ressembler
un peu escaut faut en confirmant
elisabeth bornes le président ne fait
pas le constat que nommer quelqu'un
d'autre ça ne changerait pas grand chose
et notamment vous même à matignon ça ne
changerait pas grand chose à la
situation d'abord vous n'avez pas bien
dégoûté parce que j'ai dit qu'il voulait
une femme oui d'accord enfin si c'est
les jeunes ses géants mais si c'est le
seule chose qui pose problème enfin pour
vous ce probablement pas une différence
importante mais non c'est pas ce que je
dis
quelques-uns d'entre nous c'est
substantiel donc eu donc non je savais
que que c'était son choix
je pense est l'unique raison je pense
que l'on ne peut pas écarter la
nécessité de ce changement d'un
changement de premier ministre non de ce
changement de pratique de méthodes d'
approche que je décris alors justement
en entrant dans le détail de cette de ce
changement potentiel emmanuel macron
toujours dans cet entretien à l'agencé
france presse demande elisabeth bornes
de sonder les oppositions de construire
pour début juillet je le disais une
équipe d'action des communistes aux
républicains est-ce qu'on peut gouverner
aujourd'hui en 2022 en france dans le
contexte que vous venez de décrire avec
à une équipe constituée
des communistes aux républicains alors
je je ne crois pas que ça pourra se
faire
je je je je n'imagine pas que cette
formule là qu'on pourrait appeler
l'union nationale j'ai dit se rapprocher
le plus possible de l'union nationale
c'est ce que j'ai dit il ya une semaine
mais se rapprocher le plus possible ça
veut dire que je pense que ce n'est pas
possible ni en national je ne vois pas
des forces politiques élue dans
l'opposition
entrée dans la majorité parce qu'ils
auraient le sentiment est d'ailleurs ce
serait tomber
de se renier de deux d'avoir menti à
leurs électeurs donc je ne crois pas
cette forme mais alors pourquoi le dit
il pourquoi n'y en a trop dit il savait
quoi ont-ils ces parties spécifiques ne
vous voyez bien ce qui ce qui se passe
il est parti du plus à gauche ou plus
haut plus à droite parce que il se
trouve qu'en effet des responsables
politiques fabien roussel a dit que
bon mais pourquoi pas il est revenue
chez ensuite c'est ça on écarte nord
mais mais mais c'est à peu près je fais
une traduction libre mais je suis à peu
près dans le bon bon mais pourquoi pas
et un certain nombre de responsables des
républicains ont dit bon mais pourquoi
pas
la vérité est que ça ne se fera pas sous
la forme des partis politiques et qu'ils
se rallieraient ou des groupes
parlementaires qu'ils se rallieraient
aux halles à la majorité présidentielle
monsieur bayrou se faire au débauchage
je n'y crois pas bon attendez que je
présente utilise les mots de coalition
quand on utilise le mot de coalition
c'est qu'on imagine bien que ce sera sur
la base de deux d'alliances avec des
partis d'ailleurs je vous amène dans la
semaine prochaine elle rencontre les
chefs de partis donc il ya une sorte de
décalage entre ce que vous nous dites
est ce que dit le président de la
république oui bon ça va arriver
j'espère que non d'abord simple égalité
d'abord ça peut arriver mais je ne crois
pas une seconde que ça je pense que le
président de la république n'a pas du
tout l'idée que les coalitions vont
devenir possible n'a pas du tout l'idée
que que les que de nouveaux contrats
vote je crois pas peut-être le sens de
la persuasion va faire bouger des choses
je dis que je n'y crois pas moi
personnellement peut-être je suis vous
savez dans les pyrénées on est un peu
lent donc peut-être c'est ça donc en
revanche ce à quoi je crois je vais
reprendre les termes que j'ai utilisée
par ce que semble que ça ressemble à ça
je crois à un gouvernement des bonnes
volontés
et je crois aux majorités d'idées alors
pardonnez moi je suis au bureau mais sur
la première partie de votre
idf1 de des mots que vous employez
ça n'est pas du tout une pratique
différente emmanuel macron a fait ça en
2017 en allant chercher des gens de la
société civile en allant chercher des
gens qui n'étaient pas dans son camp
donc à rien ou vous vous appelez à de
nouvelles pratiques politiques la
majorité d'idées peut-être parce qu'il y
est contraint mais constituer une équipe
de bonne volonté sur fait non je vais
essayer de vous montrer la différence
la pratique précédentes
s'étaient conformés des majorités pour
soutenir le projet du président de la
république
ok ça
et moi je pense qu'il faut c'est
pourquoi j'emploie le mot de bonne
volonté il faut constituer des équipes
capables de porter un projet qui soit
défini par le gouvernement
qu'ils soient
présentés et discutés avec les groupes
parlementaires avant d'être mise au
point
ça n'est plus une chambre
d'enregistrement c'est un parlement
voulait revenir à l'essence de l'article
dans la constitution je veux revenir
exactement au
principe de la vème république
je rappelle les principes de la vème
république
de gaulle a dit ça dans le discours de
bayeux et c'était un moment formidable
c'était 46 de gaulle a dit il venait
d'être venait de quitter le pouvoir
parce qu'il était paralysé
après avoir libéré la france un art près
quitte le pouvoir il fait ce grand
discours à bayeux sur les institutions
et l'enregistrement existe il est
formidable et il dit
nous allons enlever l'exécutif aux
manoeuvres parlementaires ça c'est les
coalitions j'ai jamais été pour ça au
sens propre du terme c'est à dire sur
les appareils de parti qui décide entre
eux qu'est ce qu'on va faire
ça a été écarté par la vème république
il y en aura un président de la
république
qui composera le gouvernement en tenant
compte des nuances de l'assemblée
nationale à la le gouvernement n'a pas
être soumis à l'accord préalable des
parties
je sais que tout le monde l'a oublié
mais ceci est la cinquième république en
revanche le gouvernement doit tenir
compte des différentes sensibilités
[Musique]
sont mises à ton peuple si justement on
vient pas du tout encore parlé déjà des
pales d'affaires d'appareils vous
comprenez benjamin ci parce que le
président on applique dit dans cette
interview partis de gouvernement et en
l'occurrence la france insoumise et le
rassemblement national merci c'est pas
la même chose on les exclut les biens
mettons que j'ai une vision légèrement
différente
ma vision à moi c'est que je ne crois
pas que ça puisse se faire par des
accords d'appareil de partis politiques
et que donc il ne faut ni sa part car un
sip aucun parti on représente au
gouvernement si on peut des sensibilités
du pays n'arrivait pardon c'est très
important ça veut dire que si on pouvait
il faudrait donner au rassemblement
national qui a 90 députés un ministère
des propositions il faudrait donner ça
la france insoumise un ministère ça
c'est la 4ème république
c'est à dire on part des partis les
partis font naître une coalition et
chaque parti exige sa représentation en
la coalition à la libération les
communistes avaient les transports il y
avait le travail et puis on donnait le
ministère de la défense où le ministère
des affaires étrangères aux partis
politiques dont je suis le porteur
aujourd'hui et puis on donnait donc pas
la traverse à non je
vais sur deux phases
je suis un défenseur de la vème
république
la vème république elle s'appuie où elle
devrait s'appuyer elle n'a pas fait
suffisamment depuis des décennies sur le
pluralisme
organiser un pluralisme qui régulait par
le président de la république est élu au
suffrage universel mais ça fait des
années qu'on a cru que l'élection au
suffrage universel donner tous les
pouvoirs au président de la république
on se trompe ça fait des années que le
gouvernement n'est considéré que comme
le décalque du président de la
république on se trompe et ça fait des
années que le parlement et considérer
simplement comme une chambre
d'enregistrement qui lèvent la main pour
voter oui tout en se disputant parce
qu'on se dispute beaucoup au parlement
et je pense qu'on se trompe à dont je
suis pour le retour à la 5ème république
c c'est bizarre mais c'est comme ça
qu'il faut vous n'avez pas été d'être
suffisamment précis est ce que dans le
cadre en plus on sait que ça le débat
j'étais la majorité présidentielle est
ce qu'il faut aller sur certains textes
sur certaines propositions
est ce qu'il faut aller chercher les
voix du rassemblement national ou pas
qu'elle est veuve au parlement on ne
cherche pas les voies
parlement quand c'est un parlement de
plein exercice quand tout ça et teki
latex au parlement le gouvernement
présente un texte
les ministres essaient de convaincre non
pas les parties mais les députés
femmes et hommes que vont été élu au
suffrage universel qui aimait la réalité
les certains sont bien partis d'autres
pas et à partir de là on recueille leurs
votes
leur amendement quand on prend des
amendements si on les trouve logique
mais est-ce qu'il faut discuter avec
l'assureur nationale c'est ça quand même
la question en france avis je brillais
au parlement le devoir d'un gouvernement
et de discuter et de dialoguer avec tout
le monde
une question monsieur bayrou juste parce
que pour préciser un peu pour ceux qui
nous vous dites coalition y en aura pas
union nationale de toute façon c'est pas
réaliste même quand le nouveau corps le
présent d'un flic 10 des républicains
aux communistes donc si on vous écoute
c'est à dire que vous constatez qu'il
n'y aura pas d'accord de partie vous
constatez d'une certaine manière que les
tractations qui vont avoir lieu avec
elisabeth bornes ne sert pas à grand
chose et qu'à la fin de la semaine
emmanuel macron elisabeth bornes
nommeront un gouvernement en allant
prendre éventuellement quelques
personnalités issues d'autres familles
politiques et que ce sera des majorités
au cas par cas donc en fait exactement
ce qui était prévu au début je dis pas
au cas par cas jeudi des majorités
d'idées oui d'accord cas par cas ça veut
dire marchandage faux-pas feu la
frontière
il faut faire attention au langage qu'on
utilise est ce que à quoi servent les
reculs et s'ils vont avoir lieu cette
semaine ben c'est une vérification pour
voir qui est capable qui a envie
c'est sûr que ça marche pas moi je n'y
crois pas je
je crois au dialogue
mais je ne crois pas aux tractations qui
permettrait de faire des accords
d'appareil a pas il n'y a pas de la
politique pour politicienne pour des
choses sans verrou dire que emmanuel
macron prend la france à témoin qu'il a
essayé qu'il a proposé c'est déjà pas
mal la france est témoin claude a essayé
oui mais bon on est jeune et déjà on est
d'engager la tique on est déjà une
petite chose c'est quelque chose qui
tient qui qui donne aux français le
sentiment qu'on peut les entendre c'est
bien d'essayer moi je crois qu'il faudra
dépasser ce stade pour trouver la
nouvelle méthode les nouvelles approches
qui me paraissent nécessaires mais en
même temps dans cette interview à l'
effet on voit bien que le projet
présidentiel et il est grave extrêmement
cadré encadré donc comment est ce que
vous voyez la marge de manoeuvre de ce
gouvernement que vous venez nous décrire
sachant que le projet présidentiel
comprennent la pas de hausse d'impôts la
réforme des retraites on voit bien qu'il
ya un cadre très rigide c'est pas un
cadre rigide ce que fait le président de
la république dans cette interview c'est
énuméré les principaux chapitres sur
lesquelles on gouvernement va essayer de
résoudre les problèmes du pays alors
qu'à three si quelqu'un vous dit qu'il
n'y a pas de problème de finances
publiques envoyé le mois si quelqu'un
vous dit qu'il ya pas de problème de
retraite envoyé le mois si quelqu'un
vous dit
d'éducation
oui je pense que ce serait un mauvais
signal alors nous allons penser cette
émission devrait dans un instant devant
ce manga lille et françois bayrou ce
midi dans des fn politique reste avec
nous
[Musique]
françois bayrou est l'invité de bfm
politique se ce dimanche nous revenons
ensemble sur cette interview donnée par
le président de la république l agence
france presse hier vous nous dites qu'il
faut changer de méthode
c'est un peu ce qu'il dit aussi vous
nous avez tout à l'heure je ferai tout
ce que je peux pour peser non
sédentaires jeu pour aider pour aider
oui bah du coup c'est un peu la même
chose rabais vous voyez bien que c'est
pas tout à quel niveau vous souhaitez
vous aider monsieur bayrou est ce que ça
passe par une présence votre présence
dans cette équipe qui sera constituée
dans le jeu
ne je ne suis pas candidat pour être
ministre mais je reviens à la grille
n'est pas parler quelle manière d'un jeu
parce que vous voulez des gens qui
soient pour raisons politiques vous
l'êtes vous voulez aider lequel nos
moyens d'aider que d'être à l'intérieur
je reprends pour répondre à votre
question je reprends au fond le sens des
questions que vous posez
et les questions que vous posez c'est
est-ce que cette situation rend la
france un gouvernant bhl ou est ce
qu'elle est gouvernable ça la question
au fond moi je crois télé gouvernable
parce que la majorité est arrivé très
nettement en tête le
le blog majoritaire ensemble à plus de
110 sièges de plus que le premier bloc
ou la première coalition de l'opposition
enfin c'est un énorme résultat dassin k
map uniquement président ah oui on peut
dire ça je vous assure que si les chefs
de gouvernement européens vous entendez
ceux qui n'arrivent jamais à avoir plus
de 20 ou 25 % des sièges je crois qu'il
vous approuverait pas donc il ya 245
sièges et le la première coalition
derrière un à 135 donc vous voyez bien
la différence donc il y à un bloc une
capacité pour gouverner mais il faut
tenir compte de toutes les sensibilités
que les français ont envoyé vous savez
françois n'a tout
françois mitterrand il avait une formule
il disait je prendrai ce que les
français m'enverront c'était c'était un
de ces line motifs et c'est comme ça
qu'il faut gouverner il faut considérer
que les français nous ont envoyé un
message pour moi un message considérable
un message extrêmement fort que ce
message doit nous obliger à changer en
tenant compte de leur sensibilité en
tenant compte de ce qu'ils disent moi je
ne suis pas pour
dans le débat parlementaire pour
ostracisé je pense que tous les
parlementaires ont des droits égaux mais
pardonnez moi parce que j'ai du mal à
vous suivre monsieur bayrou pourtant je
vous écoute avec beaucoup d'attention ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire quoi dans la
façon dont le pouvoir sera exercée dans
les semaines les mois les années qui
viennent est ce que vous dites
simplement respecter le parlement en
ayant des débats constructifs en
écoutant les uns surnom alors jusqu'où
va bien je sois je verrai si je vais
reprendre parce que je vous ai déjà
répondu à la question dans cette
émission je reprends je pense qu'il ne
faut pas arriver avec des projets tout
fait je pense qu'il faut arriver avec
des principes avec des orientations avec
des bases
de la situation qu'on peut faire
respecter par tout le monde et avant que
le gouvernement dès l'abord son propre
projet je pense qu'il faut qu'ils en
parlent qu'ils consultent il dialogue
prenant en exemple prenons l'exemple de
la réforme des retraites vous comprenez
la différence comprends très bien mais
le gouvernement va arriver imaginons
qu'il soumette au parlement le texte
originel c'est à dire 65 ans plus tôt
pour un départ à la retraite en france
le rn va dire non
la nuit baisse va dire non et comment
peut-on avoir les secours et un échange
constructif et c'est parce que vous avez
trop l'habitude de des modes de
fonctionnement d'avant mais sur quoi
peut-on lâché sur quoi pouvez vous
lâcher du lest sur la réforme des
retraites par je vais je vais finir de
répondre ça va répondre aux deux ans
nous on est complémentaires en eau est
extrêmement complexe brillant est
extrêmement complet alors comment fait
on au lieu d'arriver avec le texte que
vous dites par exemple moi je crois
qu'il y à d'autres marges de manoeuvre
je pense qu'on peut discuter avec les
différentes forces
pour obtenir les résultats qu'on a fixé
à l'avant ce qu'est ce que c'est les
résultats colin fith yadav ans
l'équilibré des régimes de retraite à
terme le fait que des forces syndicales
par exemple puisse avoir des
responsabilités dans la gestion du
régime de retraite le fait alors c'est
une des marottes qu'on puisse peut-être
choisir davantage d'inciter les gens à
travailler que de mettre le couperet des
âges exemple très concret ce que pour
moi il augmenter la durée de cotisation
plutôt que d'allonger l'âge est ce que
ça ça pourrait être versé à la
négociation je peux je pense qu'on peut
même faire mieux talent hier parce que
il ya des gens que un petit coup de
pouce suffirait a incité à prolonger
leur activité professionnelle
il y en a d'autres qui sont épuisés plus
on se rapproche de la vie comme elle est
en se fixant des objectifs mais en fait
ça veut dire monsieur bériault que vous
adressez est finalement presque gelé
repas ans voire plus aux oppositions cas
la majorité que les oppositions vous les
entendez depuis le deuxième tour de la
présidentielle depuis deuxième tour des
législatives sur les retraites pour
poursuivre notre exemple rester concret
toutes et tous disent non non non et non
adele non mais le devoir du gouvernement
c'est de ne pas s'arrêter à ce nom
le devoir du gouvernement qui comme vous
le savez dans l'article 20 détermine et
conduit la politique de la nation de
voix du gouvernement c'est de dire le
président de la république a fixé un
certain nombre d'objectifs précis c'est
objectif c'est l'équilibré des régimes
de retraite c'est le fait que l on
trouve un mécanisme de gestion qui sont
un mécanisme durable dans le temps que
les français le sentiment qu'au fond
tout ça est assez juste est-ce qu'on
peut
mettre au point avec la majorité bien
sûr et avec les oppositions un texte qui
donne au parlement une capacité d'
influence est donc une possibilité
d'adopter comprenez c'est extrêmement
différent du mode de fonctionnement
vous déversez presque romantique
françois bayrou dans le fonctionnement
actuel de jeu soit romantique je veux
bien être romantique je veux bien être
romanesque que si vous voulez ça tout ça
vous dérange pas vous pouvez idéaliste
vous êtes penser que je vais bien et
réalise c'est parce que juste tout à
l'heure vous disiez je n'ai jamais dit
ça fera sur france inter précise les
temps exige que le premier ministre ou
la première ministre soit politique
qu'on n'ait pas le sentiment que c'est
la technique qui gouverne le pays pardon
mais ces écoutes on se dit c'est ce que
je viens de décrire revenir et je n'ai
pas vraiment elisabeth bande capable
précisément de faire de la politique
elle dit que oui et le bilan de la
république a jugé que oui et les mois je
serai là pour aider d'accord justement
pour aider pour faciliter pour
un poids de jouer l'avenue genou avec
isabelle borne attendait quand même une
question si vous permettez françois
braud est ce que elle doit quand même
dans le cadre de quoi affirmer sa
position est-ce qu'il faut un vote de
confiance vis-à-vis du nouveau
gouvernement et des lois mais c'est très
important vous avez l'air dans la même
situation michel rockeur ne l'a pas fait
mais là aujourd'hui ce que c'est
possible on n'est plus à l'époque du
michel rocard ces listes verts non
difficile parce que demander le vote de
confiance s'est demandé aux oppositions
de se ranger dans la majorité et je vous
ai expliqué que je n'y croyais pas et je
pense qu'il faut du purell y compris
dans la majorité mais ça va pas l'effet
lumière la chaleur non je crois pas je
plaide pour qu'il y ait du pluralisme y
compris dans la majorité je plaide pour
que des voies différentes
peut-être parfois un peu iconoclaste par
exemple puissent se faire entendre
demandiez le rôle que notre parti
politique peut jouer
parti et de vous mêmes bah c'est déjà
pas si mal parce que de plus de 20% des
sièges de la majorité donc c'est à dire
qu'il faut plus de deux ministres modem
par exemple le télésiège du dernier
gouvernement ce que vous nous avez enfin
vous répondre ma réponse est oui mais ça
n'est pas un sujet de chantage je pense
qu'on doit trouver un équilibre
je crois que d'ailleurs tout le monde a
compris que c'était ce que nous
cherchions on doit trouver un équilibre
mais je me refuse je me refuse à faire
du chantage et du bras de fer sur ce
sujet si ça va on y sera si je n'allais
pas en direct les chaussons sont très
simples
on n'est pas au marché aux bestiaux j'ai
vendu des veaux au marché aux bestiaux
je sais ce que c'est mais mais mais on
n'est pas un marché aux bestiaux on est
dans j'espère une république de bonne
foi
c'est-à-dire civique savez l'éducation
civique c'est l'éducation à la
citoyenneté c'est au fond si je devais
définir ce que je crois nécessaire et
que je vous décris en parlant de
président gouvernement parlement et
citoyens c'est qu'il faut que l'on fasse
naître de la responsabilité à tous les
étages de la société française alors
justement et la responsabilité sur
l'entreprise vous avez et la
responsabilité dans le monde de la
démocratie sociale et de la
responsabilité dans le monde mais sur
l'aéro citoyenneté poli je voudrais
revenir juste un instant parce que tout
ce dont nous nous parlons depuis tout
cohérent je pense et surtout est la
conséquence des élections législatives
en fait les français en un sens on dit
au président de la république ben vous
ne nous avez pas écouter donc nous on va
vous donner une forme de proportionnelle
ou en tout cas les résultats qu aurait
peut-être pu donner une proportionnelle
vous avez raison de 2h et la tête parce
que vous comprenez le détail des
institutions et pourquoi ce ne serait
pas exactement pareil mais pour
schématiser pardon pour le raccourci
intellectuel l'assemblée ressemble plus
à la france manifestement heureusement
vous dit heureusement mais cette réforme
que vous appelez de vos voeux vous
l'aviez roadie sur ce plateau je la
redemander me l'art promis voulait pas
eu alors qu'est ce que les français ont
leur et compte renforcer un on l'aura je
voudrais attirer votre attention sur une
chose j'ai fait il ya un peu plus d'une
année
une on a écrit une lettre ouverte que
j'ai fait astier à tous les responsables
de l'opposition
de jean luc mélenchon jusqu'à marine le
pen en passant par les écologistes
en passant par tout ce qui était les des
centristes
indépendant de l'open tout le monde a
signé sauf l air et le ps l'appareil du
ps parce qu'il ya beaucoup de pièces qui
ont signé en tant qu' en tant que tel
rebsamen par exemple à signer bon ben
c'est le moment de le faire nous sommes
dans une situation dans laquelle en
effet les français ont dit excusez nous
mais votre mais le pouvoir
monopolistique on n'en veut plus c'est
simple comme vous vous dites nous ce que
vous avez l'engagement du président de
la république à nouveau ce qui s'était
déjà engagé qu'il allait à faire dans
les cinq ans cette réforme de ben la
voilà il à faire il l'a dit publiquement
dans son mythique et bien
il faut prendre l'habitude de faire ce
qu'on dit sur des points importants qui
sont des points du cadre de la
démocratie française ça c'est un cadre
et ça change définitivement le rôle du
parlement parce que définitivement le
parlement sera indépendant est
définitivement on aura plus toutes les
questions de deuxième tour qui se
reportent sur qui avec les reports
absolument baroque que nous avons vécu
là l'extrême gauche à voter pour
l'extrême droite l'extrême droite a voté
pour l'extrême gauche lr à voter pour
les hommes il ya eu des reports
absolument inattendu qui explique le
résultat inattendu mais significatif à
faire ça veut dire que ça veut dire que
les gens ne voulaient plus du monopole
du pouvoir et je suis je puis à tester
le président de la république lui même
depuis des années interroge cette
question du monopole du pouvoir mais en
même temps est ce qu'on appelle
sentiment rapidement mais finalement à
vous écouter emmanuel macron jupiter ils
méritent un peu cette défense cette
défaite à la force d'avoir ignoré le
mans non mais moi si je voulais bien
m'éviter désormais j'en ai déjà assez
non je pense pas ça je pense que le
alors je vais être sérieux
je pense j'ai beaucoup parlé avec lui je
pense que le président de la république
avait en lui deux intuitions
ces deux intuitions n'était pas
absolument sur la même ligne la première
intuition ceux qui pensaient qu'il
fallait changer le pouvoir et la
deuxième à puissions ce qu'il fallait
que le pouvoir soit efficace et
beaucoup de gens pensent imagine que
l'efficacité du pouvoir est
contradictoire avec le pluralisme moi je
ne le crois pas je pense qu'on peut
inventer les chemins différents pour que
ce soit le cas quelques questions s'il
vous plaît liés à l'actualité et ce
matin les français ont peut-être pu
découvrir pour ceux qui lisent la presse
quotidienne les premiers mots de pap
ndiaye ministre de l'éducation il
accorde sa première intervention dans la
presse il confiant les ans les
augmentations pour tous les enseignants
pour tous avec un bonus pour je le cite
ceux qui voudront aller plus loin est-ce
qu'on est dans un processus pour sur un
sujet vous connaissez par coeur de
libéralisation de l'école non
la libéralisation n'est pas adapté à
l'école enfin je dis ça je suis sûr que
le glisse de l'éducation nationale n'est
pas loin de penser comme moi
alors qu'il y est il ya depuis longtemps
je vais prendre un exemple les heures
supplémentaires
heures supplémentaires c'est les
enseignants qui acceptent de faire plus
d'heures ont un salaire augmenter ça
s'est de tout temps à jamais et c'est
justifié
mais je je je pense que je pense que
le monde de l'éducation et un monde qui
attachent un prix très important à
l'égalité il est il a toujours la
crainte que
on vienne
emma leur donner aux chefs
d'établissement la liberté de choisir
leurs enseignants est ce que ça va avec
ce que vous dites je suis en désaccord
d'accord au moins c'est clair
l'expérience à marseille qui vise être
alors mais peut-être plus tôt il peut y
avoir des expériences qui vont bien
après dream à peine d'y aller dit que ça
va être une analyse on peut donne plus
on peut donner plus de liberté mais moi
alors à titre personnel titre d'ancien
ministre de l'éducation un titre
d'enseignant je ne je ne suis pas
favorable à ce qu'on transforme le chef
d'établissement en patron
de l'établissement parce qu' il peut y
avoir de très bons chefs d'établissement
et il peut y avoir des chefs
d'établissement qui sont moins bons et
j'avais j'avais écrit autrefois dans un
livre sur ce sujet qui s'appelait la
décennie des malappris
l'arbitraire proche et plus à redouter
que l'arbitraire lointain monsieur
bayrou aux questions d'actualité oui on
peut lire ce matin une tribune d des
patrons des grandes entreprises
françaises de l'énergie angie edf total
énergie qui demande aux consommateurs
d'économiser l'énergie ster d'aller sur
le chemin de la sobriété énergétique
pour lutter contre l'augmentation des
prix est-ce que vous pensez que c'est le
bon message et est ce que vous pensez
notamment que les français qui ont du
mal à ce voile à se chausser c'est pas
tout à fait l'énergie lumière fois dans
l'histoire de france qu'on demande
d'économiser l'énergie
dans la décennie 70 quand il ya eu la
grande crise énergétique et l'explosion
des prix
on a fait une politique pour économiser
l'énergie économiser l'énergie si j'ose
dire en reprenant une expression très
connue c'est bon pour la planète non
vous portez vos pensées l'énergie c'est
essentiellement du co2 vous pensez
monsieur bériault que le patron total
qui demande aux français de faire des
économies
d'énergie et parce que c'est bon pour
leur portefeuille la planète ça va bien
passé excusez moi il se trouve que le
patron de total je crois que c'est un
citoyen qui a une conscience assez aigu
des problèmes qui se posent alors ils
pensent à l'intérêt de son entreprise ne
pas dire le contraire vous savez les
liens entre
total l'enracinement de total dans la
ville dont je suis donc je suis le maire
et dans la région dont je suis président
le
le patron de total ça n'est pas un ce
n'est pas un capitaliste au couteau
entre les dents c'est quelqu'un qui a
une idée assez nette de l'intérêt
français par l'intermédiaire de cette
entreprise et aussi des problèmes qui se
posent des problèmes aigus qui vont se
poser notamment qui vont se poser en
termes climatique donc le jeu participe
pas aux caricatures qui voudraient en
faire un méchant picsou
question de question qu'on peut se poser
mais rapidement la loi sur le pouvoir
d'achat est-ce qu'il faut qu'elles
intègrent les propositions notamment de
la nuque ou de la nuit baisse comme le
smic à 1500 euros ou alors le blocage
des prix sur les produits de base est-ce
qu'il faut qu'elle prenne en compte ces
propositions et c'est l'application de
ce que vous venez nous démontrer pendant
une heure on a le droit de discuter et
de réfléchir ensemble mais je ne crois
pas que ces propositions soient adaptés
au contraire et celle des républicains
qu'il veut une détaxe à 1 euro 50 le
litre est ce que ça écoutez ils en
parleront avec le gouvernement d'accord
mais de vous voyez bien qu'il y avait
des différences d'approché dans cette
affaire va pas effacer les différentes
approches l'opposition
avait un projet qui a été rejetée le la
majorité avait un projet qui a été
soutenue relativement et c'est la même
chose dessous sur tous les bords
monsieur bayrou je voulais entendre
également sur un sujet très important
qui marque l'actualité très fortement
ces dernières heures la cour suprême
américaine a révoqué le droit fédéral à
l'avortement
les états les plus conservateurs sont
précipités pour interdire l'avortement
du coup chez eux et y ait une caisse de
résonance ans en france on connaît le la
lutte en france pour ce droit est
aujourd'hui plusieurs responsables
politiques de monde sa
constitutionnalisation façon de dire si
un jour quelqu'un voulait revenir dessus
ce sera tellement compliqué qu'il n'en
sera peut-être dissuadée est-ce que vous
soutenez cette constitutionnalisation
j'ai une question très bête
y'a pas de questions baisse que
est-ce que c'est utile au pays en ce
moment
d'aller organiser un référendum sur
cette question
pour que les gens qui nous comprennent
si c'est une proposition de loi
constitutionnelle cela passe forcément
par référendum il ya une autre
possibilité c'est si le gouvernement la
reprendre vivre est aussi au congrès db2
on est devant une proposition de loi
constitutionnelle pour vous c'est pas la
règle sans exception la règle c'est que
quand on passe par ce mécanisme il faut
que l'assemblée le sénat vote dans les
mêmes termes et après le référendum est
obligatoire est ce qu'aujourd'hui
franchement dans l'état où le pays se
trouve avec toutes les questions que
nous avons devant nous est ce qu'il est
bon
est ce qu'il est utile de faire ça alors
même que à ma connaissance aucun courant
politique ne remet en cause la loi veil
-le est ce qu'elle est devenue par les
évolutions différent ça c'est la
première question est juste on s'arrête
sur cette publication donc vous dites
linverse de ce que dit le groupe
majoritaire aurore bergé elisabeth
bornes qui dit qu'elle allait soutenir
la proposition de loi donc là c'est une
voix dissonante vous dit c'est pas la
priorité faut pas le faire et je dis
qu'heureusement dans la majorité on est
libre de penser différemment les
champions ne fait rien vaut pas de
réaction véniard et donc et j'ai une
deuxième question
c'est quand même surprenant que ce soit
ce qui se passe aux etats-unis qui est
très grave je vais y revenir en une
phrase ce qui se passe aux etats-unis
qui comme si on appuyer sur un bouton
entraîne un certain nombre de réactions
effervescente dans la vie politique
française moi je ne suis pas dépendant
des états unis j'ai toujours toute ma
vie plaidé pour que nous considérions
que il y à une distance que
notre société notre civilisation même on
peut dire n'est pas le décalque de ce
qui se passe aux etats-unis il ya déjà
dans le pré nous monsieur bayrou je
pense au finlandais qu'il autorise sous
conditions malte qui l'interdît et la
pologne qui l'interdît un saffour deux
peuples plus proche de nous pour
l'instant sujet pour l'instant ça dépend
des pays des états nations qui ont la
maîtrise sur ce sujet et donc le moi je
ne suis pas pour qu'on décale que la vie
politique américaine je pense que les
états unis sont dans une situation
gravissime il ya des femmes qui se
sentent menacés en france et qui disent
moi j'ai eu besoin que les politiques se
saisissent de sujets et inscrivent et
bien le droit à l'image et dans la
considère bien elle milite au journal
droit de militer mais moi je pense que
dans l'état du pays avec les questions
innombrables qui se posent
arrivé au parlement alors que man n'a
pas parlé pendant la campagne électorale
et ça fait consensus dans la classe
politique en plus c'est ça qui est un an
vous le partisan du du consensus là pour
le coup toutes les forces politiques
sont à peu près d'accord le
rassemblement national dit c'est pas
forcément un stéroïde ils sont à peu
près d'accord il le manifesteront ils
voteront pour mais j'ai droit à avoir un
regard libre sur ce genre de sujet et
c'est vous le modem je porte un nom
c'est moi c'est après le modem on
délibérera mais je pense que
multiplié les sujets d'affrontement
passionnel
c'est ce qui s'est passé aux états unis
vous souvenez brûlé le drapeau ça fait
des mois et des mois de 2 et 1 on arrive
à un pays qui est tellement divisée que
je ne suis pas sûr qu'ils puissent
survivre
je suis pas sûr que la société
américaine
puis se traverser les épreuves qui sont
les siennes sur la race sur la couleur
de peau tous les sujets qui sont des
sujets
destructeur et moi je plaide pour des
attitudes et des politiques de
conciliation et de réconciliation merci
beaucoup mentionné la route les gens
pour se désoler
différentes merci beaucoup merci
françois bayroux d'abord est avec nous
et de vie jacques saint germain merci
restez avec nous sur bfmtv je retrouve
ce soir à 18
[Musique]